how did you first hear of the tiny house
movement well actually it's citrus
interesting because maurette and I both
have read the same article and yes
magazine back in 2009 but we had we
didn't even know each other yet and so I
think um from there it was it was sort
of ongoing every few months I would you
know oh look at this tiny house you know
and for myself and then yeah I remember
I'm reading an article and magazine
about it in 2009 it was kind of this
little seed in the back of my head but
the the idea of actually going through
with it and actually building a tiny
house was not something I ever thought
that I'd be involved with and then it
wasn't until 2011 Christopher bought his
land that it's sort of from their kind
of started becoming a reality so when
you purchase the land it was in your
mind originally to build this tiny
houses actually so I've always sort of
had this dream of buying some land in
the mountains and you know having some
sort of small cabin or something on it
and so when I bought the land it was
very kind of added out of the blue I
like you know is maybe a three-day
process from when I thought maybe it's
time to buy someone to actually like
putting a contracted and because that's
how I do things burn so so then the next
step was well I want to use it so what
how can I do that sooner than later
instead of you know waiting to build a
large house and I'm also an
environmentalist so I didn't want to
build a large house I wanted just a
small place you know like a little cabin
kind of a feel and so I started you know
waiting different options and I remember
tiny house is actually from the magazine
article and so the tiny house was
actually just it was the right solution
for the sort of set of limitations I
impose on on myself and and that the
location imposed so it just worked out
really well and the reason that became a
tiny house was because I'm Christopher's
County
County like most counties actually has a
minimum house size built into the
building codes of the county so in order
to legally build a house that you can
sleep in it has to be at least 600
square feet which was just I mean to
build a 600 square foot house
Christopher wouldn't have been able to
do that himself which was really
important to him and he just didn't
really have the money to invest in that
up front so so putting them on wheels
built onto a flatbed trailer as a way to
get around the building codes because it
counts as a temporary structure so
that's why I kind of ended up being the
extreme kind of tiny house yeah the
building codes are probably the main
reason yeah that it because I probably
would've build and this is cute mind
before the film so I was just thinking
about what the best structure on the
land would be for you know when I wanted
and I have at the time was thinking of
you have 300 square feet it sounds about
right to me and which is still really
small you know but it ended up going
smaller to fit on the trailer and into
thing to about doing it to building
codes is a lot people don't realize it's
probably until they build a house but it
codes increase the cost of construction
quite a bit because they have you know
in altitude it's at 9,500 feet you know
the footings for the foundation have to
be 12 feet of the ground so there's no
way I can dig that by hand and and pour
cement myself so it just you know the
cost started adding up and then you you
know because his project I can't even
really take on myself so so the tiny
house actually just seemed like the
right fit because it was in line with
all that sort of my values and making
the dream that I had to do this project
set and is that the reason then end
result is the money that the county or
whomever ends up getting because of
building a small structure is that the
reason why 600 scorpy's yeah I mean
there's different kind of we've
interviewed a lot of people who have
sort of different views on on the
building codes and things like that the
consensus is that you know building
codes definitely are a little bit
outdated for what is needed right now
but that you know there are theories
that you know property taxes are based
on square footage so it's a way for
counties to keep the tax base up is what
some people say
other people say that it has to do with
kind of like the mortgage lobby and you
know things like that you know other
people that they were no I read that
that coats were originally kind of
written in partnership with the building
industry and the mortgage industry too
because both those industries gained a
lot from having you know larger
structures being billed so and I mean we
have talked to a lot of people who will
say you know building codes are
necessary to preserve safety and
preserve you know health and things like
that but that they really do just need
to be updated because they're a little
bit antiquated right now yeah the other
sort cynical view is that people are
opposed to your towns or post a tiny
houses because it brings down the
property values of larger houses that
they might be located next to you
although that some jedit J Schaefer from
tumbleweed tiny house company says that
uh that the research actually shows that
they that a nice tiny house doesn't have
that impact and that sometimes it can
have the opposite so you know there's
different views on the usefulness and
sort of the cause of the housing good I
mean I think it kind of goes along with
just the whole cultural mentality which
i think is shifting you know as a result
of the housing crisis and things like
that but just the idea that you want a
bigger house if you can't afford it and
that if if you have a small house it's
because you can't afford to have a
bigger house and it somehow kind of
embarrassing to have a small house but I
think that's changing
you